c'est la fuite d'une lettre de la
diplomatie américaine adressé à kaboul
qui a relancé ce sujet brûlant
dans ce document le monsieur politique
étrangère des états unis anthony blinken
encourage un projet d'accord entre
autorités afghanes et talibans pour
obtenir la paix parmi les propositions
du secrétaire d'état des états unis un
nouveau gouvernement inclusif est
provisoire dans lequel serait intégré le
mouvement islamiste
le temps de rédiger une nouvelle
constitution et d'organiser des
élections libres pour cela washington
appelle à une période de réduction de la
violence de trois mois pour relancer les
discussions entre les parties concernées
des propositions pas forcément vu d'un
bon oeil par le pouvoir en place
notre dépendance au monde extérieur ne
signifie pas que nous devions obéir à
des exigences illégitime
l'avenir du pays ne peut être décidée
par 20 personnes dans une pièce le four
est par ailleurs total concernant un
point crucial la maison blanche
respectera tel l'accord signé l'an passé
qui prévoit un retrait des dernières
troupes américaines d'afghanistan au 1er
mai prochain une questions laissées en
suspens par joe biden qui pourraient
utiliser cette incertitude comme moyen
de pression dans les semaines à venir